it takes six minutes from here to reach
the gates of downing street
eight months ago one of boris johnson's
aides turned out of this shop trailing
them a suitcase full of wine
a journey down a then deserted street
past pubs which were shut into one of
the most heavily policed corners of
london
here on a friday night in april was yet
another party in number 10 involving
boris johnson's team he has apologized i
think we now need to move on
and talk about how we are going to sort
out issues i've spent last 24 hours with
the eu talking about sorting out the
situation for the people of northern
ireland and we now need to get on with
that and of course wait for the results
of the sue gray inquiry
two drunken leaving dues the night
before this when the queen sat alone at
the funeral of her husband of more than
70 years
the head of state showing what following
the rules in force at the time looked
like
number 10 now embarrassed this is the
second occasion that boris johnson has
had to apologize to buckingham palace
but this time tory mps say it's truly
degrading
they're trying to quantify the scale of
the damage done by the contrast between
the queen sitting alone at her husband's
funeral and the tawdry image of
suitcases with bottles of wine being
wheeled into downing street
is there no limit to his shame said one
tory mp of boris johnson
families were mourning across the
country sue vosber scattered her
father's ashes alone on the same day the
latest parties happened we are supposed
to be all in this together
clearly we're not clear there's no
empathy there's no empathy for for those
that are bereaved what do you think this
does
to your memories of that day
in 2021
it tarnishes them definitely
another tory mp making clear boris
johnson should go
it is just another
event in a chapter of incidents that
should not have happened
but i do think that minds are now over
this weekend being focused
upon the need to take the necessary
action
i don't know
and i shouldn't know
how many of my colleagues have put in
letters i'm not canvassing them i'm not
seeking support for what i have done
myself
but i believe that there is a momentum
that is growing
labor called once more for the embattled
prime minister to resign everybody now
sees the prime minister as a liar who
has tried to cheat his way out and break
the rules and has set the culture within
number 10 that has told other staff and
other people that they can carry on as
normal this is not acceptable behavior
and you should recognize that today kate
josephs the former head of the kovid
task force which set the regulations we
lived under admitted she too partied in
whitehall in the pandemic
will officials lose their job to keep
boris johnson in place or will he too
need to be packing cases before long sam
coates sky news